Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my Mandalorian season 2 episode
8 finale video i'm sure you've watched it like 7
or 8 times by now there were so many big reveals
so many big twists and so many big teasers for
the future of the star wars universe through
the mandalorian and all the other spin-off series
on disney plus so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos i will
be doing episode videos for everything that's
coming up and i'll do some mandalorian season 3
videos this weekend as well once we get through
everything else there is so much stuff to talk
about we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and just leave your favorite wtf
reveal or big twist from the episode on the video
really big spoiler warning if you have not seen
the episode yet i'm going to number these a little
bit differently as we go along through the episode
and talk about easter eggs just because it's way
more to talk about than a normal top 10 video
the title of the episode was chapter 16 the
rescue so really important to the future of
the mandalorian series the chapter idea the idea
that these are books of story collections that
are broken up into chapters i'll talk about that
when we eventually get to the post-credits scene
don't worry we'll get to that but the title refers
to mando trying to rescue grogu and then obviously
a certain jedi showing up at the end to rescue
them all from the dark troopers i'll wait till we
get about two minutes deep into the video before i
actually say his name because a lot of people skip
over the spoiler warning and don't realize that
i gave it the episode was directed by peyton reed
from all the marvel movies he's directed all the
ant-man movies he's also directing the upcoming
ant-man of the wasp 3 quantum mania he also
directed season 2 episode 2 the frog lady episode
the intro theme song was a little bit different
there were a couple variations on the mandalorian
theme throughout the episode but we should also
say at the top of the video here that jeremy
bullock the original boba fett actor passed away
the day before the episode was released the cast
and crew were paying their respects on twitter
this morning so if you saw people posting about
boba fett and jeremy bullock that's why but the
episode begins with a slave 1 boba fett chasing
down dr pershing ship who's flying a lambda-class
shuttle from return of the jedi the slave one
dogfight is very reminiscent of jango fett's dog
fight with obi-wan kenobi back during attack of
the clones when they were chasing each other on
the way to geonosis boba fett takes them out with
an ion cannon which are used for disabling craft
not destroying them i actually learned that deep
cut from playing the star wars tie fighter video
game the dos version of the video game way back
in the day it stops them dead in their tracks
the two imperial pilots here you might recognize
from agents of shield they weren't really big
characters on that show but that's where they came
from before this boba fett docks the ship mando
boards with cara dune and dr pershing confirms
grogu's location and he's alive love the way they
play this loyalty apparently doesn't mean much in
this new empire as pilot 1 just immediately turns
on them i'm not with them let's make a deal and
his co-pilot shoots him dead in his tracks without
hesitation dropping this many bodies this early
in the episode is just to let you know what the
stakes are and that they're going to be a lot more
bodies being dropped you kind of expect this as a
finale it's meant to be a really big episode and
it was the other pilot turns on dr pershing taking
him hostage to save his own life not to protect
any imperial secrets he also confirms that he's a
clone engineer by trade but we knew that he worked
in cloning because of the episode 4 reveal earlier
this season and we saw the kamino badge on his
uniform way back in season 1. funny enough they
didn't completely reveal what the cloning plot
was with grogu's blood that's obviously going
to be dealt with in future seasons there were
a lot of things that they set up for some of the
spin-off series during the episode as well so i'll
talk about those when we get to those parts of the
episode remember there are two official spin-offs
of the mandalorian that they announced the
ahsoka series and the rangers of the new republic
pilot number two proceeds to antagonize cara
dune noticing her teardrop tattoo marking her
as a survivor of alderaan and starts talking about
how he enjoyed watching it get blown up because he
was on the first death star during the events of
a new hope and proceeds to go full space karen on
her do you know how many people you rebels killed
on those death stars that you blew up they also
make all the usual death star jokes which death
star were you on there are technically three now
so i love the fact that star wars characters now
canonically make fun of the fact that the empire
lacks a lot of ingenuity just reusing their old
ideas hey let's make another death star she picks
him off with a blaster shot and then they fly with
dr pershing to a new planet that we haven't been
to before this season it's hard to tell but
it looks like there's a bunch of refineries
mining some kind of resources we see Bo Katan's
mandalorian ship it looks fantastic i wouldn't be
surprised if they're selling a new version of that
toy that's way more expensive boba fett and mando
walk into the bar make all the jokes you want stop
me if you've heard this one two mandalorians walk
into a space bar even though technically they make
a bunch of references to boba fett not being a
mandalorian i'll get into that too because i think
it has a lot to do with the end of the episode
in the post-credits scene but they find bogotan
and costco reeves just drinking it up chilling out
everyone in the bar just kind of craps their pants
at the side of all these mandalorians converging
on each other but i love the way he and boba fett
move in synchronicity like they sort of move in
formation it's very militaristic but that's
part of the mandalorian culture that's just
the way they're raised they really get into it
over the idea of higher callings and what makes
a real mandalorian like boko tan says you're just
common bounty hunters i'm not really interested
in helping you with that but then he reveals
that he's actually trying to save grogu and
that he knows where moff gideon is and that
really gets her interest they do this funny
thing through the episode where they sort of
get into this knock down drag out fight between
boba fett and costco reeves which is really cool
it's really fun to see them go at it even Bo Katan
is like if we would have fought like that a couple
of years ago we wouldn't lost to the empire but
they do this weird thing where they wait to reveal
critical information until after they fought just
a little bit like oh it's grogu that you want to
save okay maybe we'll help oh you want to get moff
gideon oh you know where he is oh and by the way
it's really the dark saber that i'm after in that
ship they also lay some seeds for the future of
din jaron's mando character when he says i'll
do whatever you want just help me save the kid
the terms of the deal that he makes with her
is that he'll help her get the dark saber back and
retake mandalore and give her the light cruiser so
if you're confused after the episode about what's
going on with mando's character in future seasons
his whole quest was to take grogu to the jedi
which he did that now his new quest is bokeh tan's
quest to take back mandalore here's the thing
about all the boba fett stuff during the episode
they have this big argument she throws all this
shade at boba fett telling him he's no mandalorian
he doesn't dispute her claim either he says i
never said that i was he only tells them and told
mando back in episode 6 that the armor is his by
rights because it belonged to his father who was
a mandalorian at one time so is he or is he not a
mandalorian you could argue it either way the way
she's talking about it like the idea of being a
true mandalorian is more about taking the oath
that mando took as a child with the watch serving
this idea of a higher calling that she's talking
to mando about during the episode and boba fett
doesn't really care about that he doesn't care
about me a mandalorian he just cared about getting
the armor back they made up a whole bunch of new
slang terms for the episode too when he says
aquata calling a stiffling slimy those are not
official star wars terms they just wrote those
for the episode but obviously you understand what
they're saying to each other without knowing what
they're saying boba fett also referenced that the
empire turned mandalore the planet into a pile of
glass meaning that they bombarded it from orbit
with their star destroyers till everything on the
surface even the rocks got melted down into glass
with the plasma energy weapons we're not anywhere
close to the planet by the end of the episode so
obviously that's something that they're going to
cover in future seasons she also reminds mando
that the darksaber can't cut through pure besgar
just to hype up the fight with the best scar spear
there are a couple moments through the episode
that want to foreshadow that just to remind you
oh yeah this is the thing that we're going to pay
off really soon dr pershing explains more about
the dark troopers he says that they have gone
full droid so obviously these are from the dark
forces video game but he explains them as being
the phase 3 dark troopers they got rid of the
last remaining weakness the human inside them but
their weakness now though is their battery life
turns out they e through batteries like nobody's
business so they have to keep them in sleep mode
most of the time when they're not in the middle
of a battle there's a really big scene of Bo Katan
forming the battle plan this is actually a good
teaser for future seasons in the bigger battles
they will eventually have when they get to grand
admiral thrawn showing you how she's used to being
a leader this is obviously all just big callbacks
to the clone wars she's been doing this for a long
long time car dune explains to Bo Katan and us
the audience why she needs Moff Gideon alive for
future seasons as well to bring him back on the
show but also because he's an imperial security
bureau and he has all these imperial secrets and
information that she needs the new republic needs
that's probably set up for the plot that they'll
cover on the rangers of the new republic spin-off
series so like i said they laid a lot of track
work for the spin-off shows during this episode
as they get ready to exit hyperspace boba fett
makes a reference to Bo Katan that reminded me
of the holy trinity so you have a princess
like boba fett says take it easy princess
then you have the scoundrel the han solo the
group which would be mando and you have the
jedi which would be grogu they try to trick moff
gideon into letting the lambda-class shuttle make
an emergency landing so he won't go through the
process of scanning them and finding out who's
on board it barely works boba fett manages to
escape obviously comes back at the end of the
episode in the post-credits scene but if you've
been a big fan of katee sackhoff for a long time
she actually had almost the exact same type
of scene landing a ship the same way during
battle star the whole plan is is that they'll
go out first clear the deck and make their way
to moff gideon so she can get the dark saber and
while that's happening they create all this chaos
mando comes after them slips in to sneak rogue out
moff gideon kind of smiles kind of understanding
exactly what's happening the minute they hit the
deck and activates the dark troopers they even get
their own dubstep sounding theme music they use
the design of the ship creatively to give you some
really cool mandalorian fights like okay we have
some jet packs let's use these to our advantage
love watching the stormtrooper fall out the shield
too into the vacuum of space that's also a way
to let you know that that exists there so that
when the dark troopers come back it makes sense
when they just fly right through the shield mando
passes an ra-7 protocol droid from a new hope on
his way down the hallway mando almost manages to
close that door to get the dark troopers out but
one makes it through starts punching the crap out
of him and you start having ptsd flashbacks to the
game of thrones oberyn martell versus the mountain
fight with him getting his face smashed in by the
mountain good thing he wore a helmet this time
it doesn't look like it got dented either trusty
flamethrower won't do the trick but the best car
spear proves pretty effective at taking them down
he manages to temporarily disable the rest
of them too by venting them out into space
just like they did back during episode 3
venting all the imperials out into space
they blast their way to the bridge disabling the
cruiser's weapon systems but moff gideon obviously
has made his way to grosgu's cell and is waiting
for mando with the darksaber held above his head
giancarlo esposito does a really great job with
his classic evil guy monologue he references
taking the darksaber from Bo Katan and the fact
that he knows everything he knows the intricate
details and the inner workings of mando's armor
and his weaponry too probably they haven't
revealed this yet but probably because someone
close to mando is secretly working for the empire
you notice that moff gideon makes him drop the
blaster but not the spear because he doesn't know
that his best car it also seems like he doesn't
realize that his armor is pure best scar and the
dark saber won't cut it he double crosses mando
immediately after making that bargain with him and
he must have hit mando with at least 20 strikes of
the darksaber and it doesn't even leave a mark on
his best gar they also did a good job during this
of foreshadowing the eventual conflict between
mando and bokutan over the darksaber the whole
mythology behind it and how you have to win it you
can't just take it from someone he says that he
got everything he needed from grogu i just wanted
to study his blood because in him is the potential
to bring order to the galaxy so obviously we know
that he was studying his midichlorians they kind
of hinted the idea of trying to combine grogu's
dna with regular people and it resulting in
really deformed clones obviously people thinking
about palpatine's clones and the snoke clones
from rise of skywalker that's obviously a much
bigger story that they'll tell in future seasons
in the spin-off series i was hoping to get some
more answers about that but the funny thing is
that giancarlo esposito did an interview before
the season started saying that we wouldn't get
real answers real big answers until season 3 or
season 4 of the mandalorian so that is why there
are so many unresolved plot threads by the end
of the episode i love katee sakhoff's performance
as Bo Katan in this last part of the episode too
that devilish smile on her face as she's kind of
lording over the bridge and the immediate turn
on her face as she sees mando rolling in wielding
the dark saber like this should be a really cool
thing and he's got grogu in one hand the dark
saber and the other look at how badass this is
i think this is something everybody wanted to
see at some point i didn't expect to see it so
soon but she can't stand it and then Moff Gideon
sort of explains the mythology of the dark saber
in greater detail oh no no you can't just give it
to her you have to win it in battle it's kind of
like a harry potter elder wand situation but
then he clarifies there's no actual magic in
the dark saber the magic is all about the story
of you winning the dark saber otherwise people
will view you as a pretender to the throne so to
make another game of thrones reference mando is
kind of like the jon snow of this situation
technically he has a stronger claim to the
throne of mandalore the best car iron throne of
mandalore than Bo Katan and she is pissed about it
they do not address it at all by the end of the
episode so obviously that's going to be something
that they'll deal with in future seasons they
have to have it out over that before they can deal
with that though the dark troopers make it back on
board and Moff Gideon looks even more pleased with
himself i also love the way as he's sitting there
he sort of flips his cape to hide the blaster
turns out space capes are stylish and useful but
then as the dark troopers start laying siege to
the bridge doors luke skywalker's x-wing arrives
to save them with r2-d2 you can see that once he
gets close enough grogu can sense him through
the force and starts communicating with him
telepathically letting luke know what's happening
on board so while this is all going on grogu is
kind of giving luke the play-by-play he's sort
of like the sports commentator for the episode
there's some great reaction shots especially from
moff gideon who looks like he craps his pants
when he hears the dark troopers shut down and then
turn around and get ready for luke the reason they
probably did that is because they have proximity
sensors that can sense the greatest threat and
they sensed luke was a much greater threat than
the people on the bridge even though they waited
a little while to reveal his face and unfurl the
hood i feel like you see the green lightsaber with
the black glove hand you know exactly who that
is most of the fight moves that he's using taking
out all these dark troopers are pretty basic jedi
abilities he's fairly powerful at this point but
i feel like when you talk about really badass
jedi fights the last year or so ahsoka's fight
scenes that she had during episode 5 were actually
technically more impressive the really cool thing
about this hallway run too is that it's actually a
cool parallel for darth vader in rogue one in his
scene so like father like son papa bless he even
ends the fight like darth vader did in rogue one
crushing the last one that was probably
one of my favorite takedowns in the episode
he's dressed in the same clothes from return of
the jedi and they did the same thing that they
did with carrie fisher in rogue one using a stand
and then just swapping his face using some special
effects they've gotten better with it but it still
looks kind of weird and i feel like sebastian stan
probably would have been better like he looks
enough like luke but i understand why they didn't
want to recast they still wanted it to be the mark
hamill version of luke and mark hamill himself was
credited in the episode meaning he was actually
doing all the lines of dialogue for luke so it was
him speaking as luke and they just made his face
look really young when this scene is happening
he's in his late 20s so he's still very very
young as he walks in though they start playing
the twin sons theme song from a new hope which
is kind of luke's theme song as well he tells
mando that he would die to protect that smile but
until grogu becomes a full jedi knight he won't be
safe they have one of the saddest goodbyes in the
episode grogu kind of motions to his face he takes
the helmet off again in tough guy mando is crying
his eyes out papa bless as they say their goodbyes
r2-d2 wheels in and they have this funny meeting
with him and grogu r2-d2 is probably meeting him
again for the first time because remember r2 never
had his memory wiped he was the only one that was
around for all of anakin skywalker's childhood
up through the prequels he remembers everything
so he would have been at the jedi temple a lot
during the prequel era so he probably remembers
grogu from that period but then luke leaves with
grogu to go train him as a jedi and mando still
without his helmet just watches them go remember
now i said he agreed to join Bo Katan as part of
their deal and retake mandalore so his new quest
now that he's delivered grogu to his people to
the jedi is Bo Katan's quest to retake mandalore
but then the post-credits scene reveals boba fett
and fanuc shan at some point later maybe a small
time jump going back to jabba's palace on tatooine
killing what looks like a much older fatter
version of bib fortuna from return of the jedi
there are also a lot of other people from jabba's
palace in return of the jedi that looks like they
survived the events of that movie and have just
remained here as part of bib fortuna's court so
it seems like after jabba died he just took over
his crime syndicate and then got super thick like
jabba the reason he's speaking in huddys though is
because that's the really common language of the
underworld of the star wars universe in the crime
syndicates is very common but they also slip in a
mcclunky which most of you will remember from last
year when they released disney plus for the first
time and they aired a version of new hope with
the infamous mcclunkey i bet you have my monkey
i don't know if they included that as a joke
hopefully they don't try to make mcclunky a thing
in the star wars universe really cool behind the
scenes detail though the actor that was playing
bib fortuna also played general grievous during
revenge of the sith and he's done hundreds of
voice over roles in the star wars movies and tv
series then as boba fett kills him he sits down
on jabba's throne which you'll notice is adorned
with the metal replicas of the rancor press f in
the chat for the rancor just letting you know that
he's now taking over jabba's crime syndicate it's
sort of the same parallel for mando taking the
darksaber and now technically having a claim to
the throne of mandalore but then you get the title
reveal the book of boba fett releasing december
2021 there has been so much confusion on social
media in the past hour since i'm making this video
and the episode aired people are wondering now
if the mandalorian season 3 is just gonna follow
boba fett and mando will just be a side character
during that maybe appearing in a couple of cameo
scenes there have been rumors about a boba fett
spin-off mini-series earlier but at the disney
investor meeting star wars panel they said that
the next chapter the mandalorian season 3 would
be released christmas 2021 so because they do
these chapters of the mandalorian it could just
be that the next story arc of the mandalorian
series follows mostly boba fett's character in
the other characters like mando Bo Katan the other
mandalorians or just side characters during that
i think part of the reason for doing this and
for sending grogu off luke skywalker is so that
he can come back maybe either a season later or
a long time later and he will be more like luke
skywalker at the beginning of return of the jedi
remember what luke was like at the end of empire
strikes back he had some abilities in the force
but he was very untrained he lost his hand but
then he showed up at the beginning of return of
the jedi after a small time jump seeming like he
was way more powerful so i think it'll be the same
for grogu when he comes back but the way pedro
pascal talks about it he said that he expects
to cross over to all the mandalorian spin-off
series so he'll be in the mandalorian season 3
probably he'll also probably be in the ahsoka
series which will take place during the same time
period and the rangers of the new republic series
but they will be filming the ahsoka series in
the rangers the new republic series next year too
those won't be released till 2022. the obi-wan
kenobi series in the rogue one prequel series star
wars and or will also be released sometime during
2022 i'm not expecting a ton more luke skywalker
scenes just because it's really expensive for them
to do that and it didn't look really perfect there
was a lot of uncanny valley going on when it
got too close to his face so that's why i say
there'll probably be a couple of time jumps with
grogu's story so that he just comes back after a
while and he's way more powerful hopefully
there's at least one scene that mirrors the
yoda training scene with yoda writing on his back
and then you have grogu writing on luke's back
what'll happen is my next video will probably just
be a pure post credit scene video talking about
boba fett and what his storyline is going to be
during the book of boba fett episodes then i'll
start doing some more full mandalorian season
3 videos about all the story lines like the Bo
Katan mando stuff that's happening with the
dark saber that's a huge deal there's also a
mandalorian bonus episode with a bunch of behind
the scenes stuff that'll be dropping next week
i'll also do an episode video for that as well
but there's so much stuff to talk about so if
there's any big easter eggs that you spotted in
the episode that i didn't reference in the video
just write them below in the comments i'm really
happy with what they did this season i feel like
jon favreau and dave filoni are the future of the
star wars universe and the future of star wars is
in all these star wars series on disney plus not
so much the movies as you would normally expect
everyone click here for that new star wars obi-wan
kenobi teaser trailer video and click here for all
my mandalorian episode videos thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!